Brad Nessler here in the Honda inside a
report on the Richardson show how are
you doing Brad hey rich I'm doing better
than your Wolverines did last night even
though they know it was like a rock
fight man it was ugly it was what do you
think it was was it the late start was
it the the the was it the the the rust
of a big ten by week essentially because
the tournament was held in the garden a
week before what do you think about it
right yeah I think it might have been
that a little bit they just look rusty
you know vogner just never got in the
flow of the game Duncan Robinson same
thing they had a little trouble with
Montana speed at the guards those two
dudes were really quick especially in
the first half they you know they
settled in and played better defense
against those two guys in the second
half but yeah they were never in the
floor then and they didn't look anything
like they did when they you know ran
through the Big Ten tournament so uh you
know like John said after the game and
we only said while we were doing the
broadcast you know get that one out of
your system just spit it out burn the
film don't even go back and say here's
what we did here's what we didn't do
just look ahead to Houston because they
play like they did against Montana
against Houston they're gonna hit their
doors blown off they've got it with you
but they'll be better I mean I know
they'll be better and because they can't
play any worse yes may I've no offense
to you no no no Brad look it is what it
was it was ugly I mean Michigan hardly
turns the ball over they turned it over
almost as much on average for a game as
they did in the first half but the whole
thing just was again it started at 10:30
at night the clock the clock even
malfunctions was weird it was kind of
weird from top to top to finish you know
get about an 11 minute delay I'm
guessing that did seem like a half an
hour because not only did the clock stop
and then the clocks went out but the
scores table went out so the monitors
over there at the scores table didn't
work either so the officials had to come
over and basically I did play-by-play
for about 11 minutes three officials and
luckily I knew all three of those guys
I do all three of those guys in like ok
down to do this and they're Darren do
you do this whatever we're trying to
turn our monitors around so they could
figure out you know when the shot clock
stopped at 15 seconds and Simpsons out
there dribbling it was it was horrible I
mean
talk about a screeching halt to a game
that wasn't that good to start with so
yeah it was it was a little bit of
everything you don't want anything like
that especially when you're almost the
last game of the night that said I think
any game would have paled in comparison
to the way Houston and San Diego State
finished that was just yeah exhilarating
just to trading threes and then Rob gray
what a performance out of him tell me a
little bit more about this kid that that
we're gonna see on display and in the
round of 32 you know it's amazing thing
is he's only been in Houston for three
years played his freshman year in junior
college and he's got almost 1,700 points
in three years he's that good and great
elevation his jump shot I mean he's got
great vertical and shoots at the top of
his jump he's one of those guys it's
hard to defend because even though he's
only six one you know he shoots like
he's six six or something like that with
a jump shot because he goes straight up
he was unbelievable last night and a
career-high with 39 he's had six games
this year of 30-plus and I mean he did
everything he just carried the whole
team and I don't know if he can play
like that again but it was great at the
end of the game because you know kids
from Forest City North Carolina and he
said you know I grew up watching the Tar
Heels always being in the final 40 again
c-double-a and all that kind of stuff
and here he is at Houston and he was
very cool about saying you know I did it
for our fans I did it for the city of
Houston so I mean he's he said
everything right he's done everything
right he tore it up last night I don't
know you know who's gonna guard him I
guess Xavier Simpson probably gets the
probably gets the nod to try to guard
him but they couldn't guard him last
night that's for sure he was
unbelievable and I think the last time
anybody scored that many for Houston in
an NC double-a game was biggie so that's
good come yeah it's been a long time
right I mean it really has been a lot
and hey it's interesting you point that
out with the Astros winning the World
Series and we all know JJ Watt what he
did for the city and and what the
Rockets are going on what they're doing
right now and Houston then wins its
first NCAA Tournament game since you
know 1984 it really is a it's a neat
story Brad it really is I didn't I
couldn't believe that
their last tourney win was 84 and they
beat Virginia in overtime in that game
and it was Oh tell Wilson and all those
guys for Virginia and then they lost
Georgetown in the title game but it
seems like somewhere along the line they
would have won another chain in the NC
double-a tournament until last night so
long dry spell and you know it's a great
reclamation project too rich for Calvin
Sampson at Calvin I've been friends for
a long time and you know go back for
different schools probably especially
with Oklahoma that he took to the
tournament 11 times but you know the
troubles he had of Indiana and and I
guess some of the violations they had
there would be miniscule compared to
what we hear about now there's all phone
calls or text messages whatever but for
him to kind of redo his career and
revive the Houston basketball program at
the same time it's just a cool story I'm
happy for him I'm proud of him I'm happy
for him Brad Nessler of CBS Sports here
on the Rich Eisen show for I would say
what would you say about 14 15 minutes
on the clock
your first game looked like we were
about to see Cinderella like holy Pete
Carroll Batman we were seeing Kansas
being taken being taken point for point
by Penn what happened in that game that
finally turned outside for Kansas I
think Penn you know is better than a 16
seed like I think they sort of proved
that just the way they play kind of
messes with people's minds I think a
little bit I don't think you know Kansas
the number one seed here but Bill would
probably tell you I don't know if we're
number one seed he likes being a number
one seed but and it's nice that they're
in Kansas and they're 160 miles away
from Lawrence and all that kind of stuff
but this is not a normal Kansas team you
take away Devonte Graham and I think
they're just kind of a team to be honest
with you especially with Isaac we create
you know out they don't have an inside
presence at all you know Mitch
Lightfoot's in there played a few
minutes last year and he's starting you
know down in the post so they don't have
a they don't have a lottery pick I mean
Devonte Graham is an awesome player he
really is I mean he's the second best
performer yesterday other than Rob gray
in this in this event and he's super and
a great kid and a finalist for play
early
and all that kind of stuff but they
don't have any depth they don't have any
size but they find a way to you know win
14 straight big 12 title so they got a
Hall of Fame coach in a really good
point guard that's why they're in it but
they could be in trouble against Seton
Hall yeah I was gonna ask you Brad Seton
Hall which which handled NC State how
how can Seton Hall you know turn
Kansas's nightmare machine back on again
in this tournament I think just because
you know they got seniors all over the
place Carrington really played well at
the point last yesterday afternoon ended
up with I know I think 26 or something
like that Rodriguez has been kind of
coming back from ankle injury when he
slipped in that game against Providence
when they had the wet floor and all that
kind of stuff but you know just senior
leadership those guys have been there
done that
they've been in the tournament three
straight years but it never won a game
now they got a taste of it you know
yesterday and they got a good coach and
when you get off that many seniors I
think that just helps the cause and we
know that you know that and it pays off
you can have all the superstars in the
world that are ones and Duns or whatever
well you got three or four seniors
playing together they've been there for
years they know what to do
Brad Nessler in the Honda inside a
report calling in from Wichita Kansas
again he's gonna be calling Kansas Seton
Hall in Michigan Houston on Saturday
who's the best team do you think in this
tournament then one that you've seen in
this region no just and what do you
think I mean just overall let's take you
out of Wichita for a second Brad okay
well does that mean by Arizona the
window I guess I mean how about that
I've got like yeah I've got the buffalo
bulls coach Nate oats calling in an hour
three because I love these stories man I
just I know I heard the promo and I
heard who you had on Baker Mayfield
buffaloes coach and me my Matt's a good
company yes sir my best I don't I don't
know now because you know I sort of
filled out a bracket and I thought I'm
just gonna do it for myself I usually do
up my high school buddies or the people
I hang out when the dives in Atlanta but
I said you know I'm not going to do it
this year because I don't want it to
influence me race you know I picked
somebody in my region that kind of thing
and so I just did it for myself
yesterday and I got in front of me and
I'm done
I'm Don B Arizona I had Arizona so
forget about it my gosh you our leader
in the year and I thought you know
they're really good and you know Aiden's
like you know the number-one draft pick
and all that kind of stuff and the stuff
you know the things they went through
and I thought well they're just gonna
come back and prove to everybody that
they're really really good and then the
buffalo team said nope not not so much
Natalie Bella getting beat but getting
creamed I mean yeah it was one of those
things to wasn't you know like how
Loyola Chicago won right and it wasn't a
last-second one were or even like the
ending of Houston and San Diego State
were where the ball was in the air and
the game was on the line my way I
screwed that up in case you watched it
because I said for the client I thought
he was inside the three-point line so
that's a brand I heard that walk me
through it as a broadcaster how it's a
day after you're even bringing that up
just in case people heard that I mean
you carry that on with youth right yeah
there was one point one so you know it's
as I said catch and release like you're
going fishing and we have so many people
at that front table and I'm not trying
to but the the ref was right in my view
and all I wanted to see is that the guy
could even catch you know it was a great
throw by many go I'm gonna get it to Kel
and and then I thought GL was inside the
three-point line so uh you know I said
to Ty and it should have been to win
how'd he get it I really would have felt
that but whatever you always want one
back you know hey Brad you're one of
those I had one of those with Warrick
Dunn against Virginia and Florida State
and I had work done score in Florida
State against Virginia when they had
never lost an ACC football game and work
and I get together and he said had we
had replay he was still in so I called
Nana you want to get a couple of those
back once in a while you don't think I
do Brad hey look you're as good as they
come and like I said me and and and when
when you're when you're watching your
alma mater struggle to score points and
then you're watching around the mater
finally take the lead and then you're
listening to somebody call 11 minutes of
play-by-play of people doing wiring
you're really good at that right you're
fantastic alright I appreciate it
somebody said to me yesterday I got a
text and said we thought you were good
but we didn't know that you could do
electrical wiring for eleven minutes and
call play-by-play a man you you are
great when you're talking about plugging
in that HDMI I mean that's thanks for
calling in have a great Saturday at the
mic hi brother if you got it's Brad
Nessler than the Honda inside a reporter
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience